et bien voilà bonjour bienvenue dans ce
diagonale actualité spécial championnat
du monde toujours eloi bonjour stéphane
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur des gonades
alors on est dans une super super
actualité puisque c'est en fait le
championnat du monde et loi quand on
attendait tous depuis presque 13 ans 1
puisque depuis que kasparov a quitté la
fidh et en 93 le fameux match kasparov
short et il y avait le match parallèle
timan karpov
il ya une confusion totale d'un monde
d'échecs et ça y est la réunification se
fait entre le vainqueur de kasparov
kramnik et topalov oui alors donc
effectivement il ya eu le match kasparov
cramique qui quand même avait poursuivi
la lignée de la fidh et c'est à dire que
caisse par un grammy qui avait battu
kasparov et donc pris le titre de
champion du monde
il a remis son titre en jeu contre
critères légaux qui était un match un
peu moins légitime dans la mesure où
acteurs locaux ne méritait pas
nécessairement par des voies officielles
sont au challenge contre vladimir
kramnik cependant maintenant la topalov
à gagner à san luis en début d'année il
a gagné le championnat du monde fim et
il est donc le challenger de vladimir
kramnik et c'est un très beau match qui
devait recommencer alors challenger si
on considère le légitime comme kramnik
si on considère que légitime c'est le
titre fidh ses chroniques le challenger
à qui on reconnaît quand même la droite
souhaite qu'on fasse appel à moi en tout
cas ce qui est sûr c'est que tout le
monde sera d'accord pour considérer le
vainqueur du match comme un champion du
monde même si bon mais l'ombre de
kasparov planera toujours encore un peu
sur ce championnat puisqu'il s'est un
peu retirée en disant qu'il se retirait
aussi parce qu'il en avait marre qu ça
arrive pas on n'arrive pas à aboutir à
cette réunification
oui je ne pense pas que kasparov soit
suffisamment pointus maintenant pour
affronter un joueur comme topalov à mon
avis en tout cas quand rami déjà alors
contre chronique c'est un autre c'est un
autre problème parce qu'il ya un
problème pour le contrôle samedi
donc ça c'est un deuxième problème qui
vient s'ajouter au premier c'est qu'il
est contre ça fait longtemps qu'il n'a
pas joué donc garry kasparov n'est plus
vraiment forcément au top on sait pas
parce qu'il a pas de partie mais on
suppose que quand même ça se perd les
échecs c'est difficile quand on arrête
de jouer quand on travaille plus et bien
joue moins bien donc on suppose que
kasparov n'est plus vraiment un candidat
sérieux pour jouer ce genre de match qui
sont en très très difficile pas réservé
aux jeunes mais bon quand même qui
durent longtemps qu'ils sont très très
dur en préparation nerveusement c'est
épuisant
donc je ne suis pas sûr que kasparov
soit encore au niveau pour jouer ce
genre de match
d'autant plus que fictivement quand ils
y jouent plus puisque maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'on fait de la politique il
va essayer de restaurer la démocratie en
russie d'après ses propres dires il peut
battre la libertine bon j'ai pas sûr que
chirac les compris puisqu'il a reçu
poutine front avant-hier et qu'angela
merkel
il n'y avait pas kasparov était même
idée bon on verra
en attendant c'est le match et or ce
match a lieu à elista elista sait où
c'est la capitale de la kalmoukie ça
dans le caucase donc ce n'est pas loin
de chez kasparov finalement puisque ces
ballons et de l'arménie l'azerbaïdjan
bakou un bac ou c'est je crois ce
capital de leur mini d'où vient kasparov
surnommé à l'époque
enfin toujours l'aigle baqouba la
capitale de l'arménie s'est pas lassé
l'azerbaïdjan naseba de genre de leur
mini seven year et vachon voilà junior
qui va commencer ça fait enfin tout cas
c'est lorsque semaine c'est dans ce coin
là c'est une petite république
caucasienne de langue mongole et de
religion plutôt bouddhiste n'ayant j'ai
vu ça j'ai vu que d'ailleurs même
topalov et kramnik ont reçu des offres
de moines bouddhistes ont posé devant
est en place et c est le président de
cette république c'est aussi le
président de la fis laisser kirchen et
2009 où il veut le fameux
kerssane qui a donc détrôné qui at il
détourné d'ailleurs ce n'était pas ton
koopman s6 il a battu contre vannes s il
a succédé à quand ses parents se
séparent qui l'a battu c'est oui quand
polonaise s'est désisté s'est désisté
awsat alors me voilà donc ça fait des
années qu'il est à la présidence de la
fidh et qui est donc une institution
majeure des échecs mondiaux en la
fédération internationale des échecs car
ça 2009 qui mène sa barque à sa façon
c'est-à-dire qu'il rajoute beaucoup
d'argent que il fait des championnats du
monde un peu plus spectaculaire avec ce
système d'élimination directe qui vaut
ce qu'il vaut mais qui a quand même été
une des qualités abandonné et si elle a
abandonné mais il a une micro révolution
non mais c'est je pense était à l'essai
mais kaka pas été convaincant du tout un
mois au départ j'y crois dit d'ailleurs
aussi mais bon il s'est avéré que les
champions du monde qui sortait de ce
système
si on parle des qualifs man quasi mizan
offre votre prono marriott qui sont
d'excellents joueurs par ailleurs mais
bon qui sont même pas dans le top 10 si
vous voulez bon ça ça fait un peu tache
alors qu'on a quand même l'habitude
depuis bobby fischer d'avoir un des deux
ou trois meilleurs du monde consacré
champion du monde
donc maintenant il a rebaptisé ce
système qui était quand même intéressant
coupe du monde des échecs ce qui est ce
qui est donc intéressant et le champion
du monde est redevenu ce qu'il aurait
toujours dû rester un bon système avec
des matches impossible de match sauf que
c'est pas encore le canon alors tu vas
trop vite puisque quatre topaloff est
devenu champion du monde phil pas de nom
par le choix de quart chez 2009 à la
suite d'un tournoi
là on est revenu à un système qui avait
été utilisé une seule fois dans
l'histoire en 1948 ou botaniques avait
remporté un tournoi puisque en fait le
champion sortant alexandre liqin était
mort quelques temps avant pendant la
guerre 40 39 45 et il ya eu ce tournoi
premier bobigny que je croyais deuxième
bronstein quelque chose comme ça
c'était la seule fois où le champion
menditte signé à l'issue du tournoi et
depuis avec des matches et là on est
revenu enfin système l'âge en tout cas
ce qui est sûr c'est que médiatiquement
et pour nous c'est beaucoup plus clair
un match on a vraiment un challenger
l'auto n'en ou là ici les deux meilleurs
du monde ou considérer de meilleur c'est
clair on va voir une vraie opposition de
style c'est tous partis donc c'est
correct
on était habitué des matches plus loin
c'était à londres ce que c'était 14
parties même c'est sûr en 2000 donc ça a
été un peu réduit et avant on avait mis
des masses urbaines quatre partis qui
étaient peut-être en un peu long avant
on avait des matchs premier à ses
victoires il y avait aussi ça c'était
bien pire
voilà en tout cas voilà un match de six
mois on y est on va tout de suite voir
des images si on peut le montrer voilà
deux la kalmoukie avec la cérémonie
d'ouverture de ce championnat du monde
regardez un très beau stade avec ici des
jeunes des jeunes femmes kalmouke
déguisé en pièces d'échecs
on reconnaît quoi là je sais pas il ya
peut-être un fou un personnel mais nos
télévisions c'est peut-être un fou ça
arrive bien fait dans des bennes
cérémonie d'ouverture avec des
échiquiers vivant il avait déjà fait ça
pour les olympiades de bled il ya vu un
trade à l'échiquier vivant qui avait été
animé là bas donc effectivement il aime
bien commencé la cérémonie par des
petites animations qui sont toujours
fort sympathique à regarder là ça se
passe et stéphane 7,8 ma particularité
dans un stade de foot face à ce stade de
foot on voit l'air à l'arrière-plan
d'ailleurs le public un kéké dans les
gradins alors on peut voir ensuite une
deuxième image justement toujours on
voit bien que c'est un stade de foot
puisque l'on a le fameux couloir où
d'habitude
eh bien les joueurs de foot attendent
pour entrer sur le terrain donc on voit
qu'ils sont qui sont en attente de deux
ils sont de tantale en tout cas de
gladys est évidemment dans ce bastion
terrain stéphane lenny kravitz façon
plus plutôt un boxeur j'ai l'impression
qu'il a l'air vraiment sûr de lui il
arrive des consentements renvoi fasciné
ghazi loi on va te voir en un cru cela
c'est là tout de suite on va en voir on
voit ici d'ailleurs que les joueurs
tiennent tiennent ici la main à des
jeunes filles kalmouke aussi alors qu'il
saluait officiel ségur tomlison l'
arbitre international hollandais qui est
sur la gauche
donc c'est un l'arbite de référence 1
c'est lui la star mondiale de
l'arbitrage des chèques sémites il
rédige des règlements et celle tout à
fait à droite et celui tout à fait à
droite et un inconnu
c'est un personnage il est peut-être
oui doit être arbitre assistant très
probablement celle à convaincre indique
énorme quand même à comparer à tout le
monde à celui le plus grand devant la
photo alors on va passer à l'image
suivante superbes photos aussi on a les
deux joueurs qui rentrent tels des stars
de foot elle des stars de je ne sais
quoi d'europe des rockstars devant le
public et qui rentre sur le terrain
c'est à l'état de la stepway est pas non
plus un concert des rolling stones c'est
maintenant c'est de deux joueurs qui
sont bas deux adversaires qui arrivent
sur le terrain passé la présentation des
joueurs dont ils sortent de leur couloir
et il arrive sur la pelouse
photo je trouve en tout cas et on va
voir enfin la dernière image qui est non
pas le dernier encore si une image alors
cette fois c'est sûr le banc de touche
voilà donc on voit bien à gauche le
fameux inconnu ensuite gucht
hinse n 10 andy c'est notre fameuse
arbitre kramnik kirchen ou inneov
topalov et florencio compo monnaie ce
qui est toujours président honoraire de
la fédération internationale des échecs
qu'il est toujours invité par qui
chemine of en général à tous les tous
les événements protocolaires claudio
canton madness qui est une machine à
gagner des élections qui conseille
toujours pire ça mieux nov
pour ces élections est la fille d est en
fait un match tu l'envoies la conférence
de presse après la première partie
après la première d imaginer le résultat
voilà donc la tête des deux joueurs
voilà donc peut-être en tout cas on va
en parler tout de suite voilà donc
conférence de presse mail photos aussi
en tout pas la face et concentré le
regard un peu dans le vide et kramnik
qui a l'air ma foi assez content mais
parce qu'ils pensent que ce soit il va
pas les livres d'être allé lieu au
cinéma voilà donc on voit la pensée
quelques photos de présentation on va
voir évidemment maintenant cette
première partie alors le tirage au sort
a désigné les blancs pour kramnik elle
reste un avantage à seul inconvénient
alors c'est une question intéressante le
le point d'entrée du match c'est pas la
partie la plus importante c'est à dire
que aussi c'est une partie très
importante la première partie puisque ça
va donner un peu le rythme du match mais
néanmoins que comme très important c'est
d'avoir les blancs dans la dernière
partie parce que si on est dos au mur
obligé de gagner
eh bien on sera fier largement jouée à
quelques pièces blanches parce que on a
le premier coup on a de meilleures
chances de gain en à l'initiative et
donc c'est mieux
donc quand on a les noirs dans la
première on a les blancs dans la
dernière puisqu'on va jouer s'il faut
avec les blancs s'il faut être les noirs
dans ce match donc avantage topalov pour
la forme pour la fin la fin du fin de
championnat mais des avantages peut-être
un petit peu s'ils n'arrivent pas à s'en
sortir dans cette première partie ça
risque de me casser le moral un petit
peu mais totale d'acier quand même alors
on y va
cette première partie entre est entré
deux matches donc ce fameux championnat
du monde unifié que tout le monde
attendait depuis depuis très longtemps
cramique va enclencher les débats donc
avec les blancs face à topalov et il
démarre donc ça c'est très important
puisque en général en deux matches quand
on choisit une ouverture on va s'y tenir
le plus longtemps possible donc on peut
faire des variations mais souvent c'est
si c'est peut-être pour pour même des
fois pour prendre des jours de repos
pour parce que l'adversaire veux pas
trop entrer des choses qui n'a pas trop
prévu mais a tout de suite on voit que
cramique et bien ne varie pas pareil que
quand tu casses marrant fille joue des
quatre oui alors vladimir kramnik a une
énorme expérience du coup
l'avancée du plan dame du coût des
quatre ou de jouer cavalier 3 il ne joue
que très rarement eu quatre il a joué
avec des succès relativement faible
c'est à dire que ça lui réussit pas son
style est bien en accord avec le coup
d'avancé du grand dam des quatre donc
vladimir kramnik qui joue son coup
favori et c'est tout à fait naturel
maintenant ce qui est très intéressant
de voir c'est la réponse de topalov
parce que topalov joue une multitude
d'ouverture qui vont du gambit dame
sérieux en passant par enzo jusqu'à la
benoni voir les stands hier et de temps
en temps
total offre un choix illimité
pratiquement deux variantes à sa
disposition quand il a les caisses
noires
donc c'est surtout l'un qui était la
question le fait que chroniqueuse des
cats ne représente pas vraiment une
surprise mais d'abord on va se poser la
question dès la deuxième partie une
chronique orale et blanc c'est à dire
bien lors de la troisième partie
on verra si topalov joue la même
ouverture ou va imprimer sur ce match
peut-être une nouvelle façon de jouer
des matches c'est à dire de peut-être de
changer à chaque fois pour éviter
justement tout type de préparation et et
mettre l'adversaire en position de
critique
alors j'essaie de changer chaque fois
stéphane ça n'a jamais été utilisée
voilà sérieusement mais par un candidat
ou chapelles du problème est ce que toi
pas là ce ne serait pas capable de ça
topalov et peu expérimenté en match où
il a quand même dû évidemment étudié les
grands matches et l'histoire il n'est
pas idiot puisqu'il fait partie des
meilleurs joueurs du monde il va donc
développer une stratégie intéressante
fidèle à son style
deux combattants maintenant
effectivement je pense quand même qui
devrait s'orienter vers le choix d'une
ouverture
c'est à dire qu'il va continuer à jouer
la même chose dans les partis avec on
verra qui vivra verra
on en parle on ne sait pas alors
cavaliers et 6 voilà la réponse de nos
topalov alors on peut dire et voilà la
réponse la plus souple 1 face à d4
puisque puisque ça permet tous les types
de variantes on peut encore jouer les
candidats n'a pas cédé 5
on peut encore jouer les variantes
ndjana passe de g6 on peut même
envisager parfois de jouer le coup c'est
sa rentrée dans des systèmes de type
benoni voire d'un bingo pour les blancs
après en poussins b 5 donc c'est le coup
le plus souple puisque quasiment tout le
temps dans les dents les particuliers de
d'options d'arbres on va sortir les
carrières 6 essentiellement je pense
qu'on peut le dire c'est pour contrôler
cette case
4 wyss évoqué rapidement sortir une
pièce tous les avantages d'un coût de
couverture c'est certain maintenant
effectivement ces deux là c'est pas une
question de souplesse c'est tout
simplement gens qui avaient des six bons
il sait ce qu'il va jouer mais il
n'annonce pas tout de suite on sait pas
voilà il ya des prêts qui veut se garder
un maximum d'options parce que là on est
dans les premiers ou les deux joueurs
savent exactement ce qu'ils veulent
faire
donc je veux dire si ce nombre devrait
se passer de commentaires donc ces
quatre classiques parce qu'à ce niveau
là c'est le coup le plus le plus usité
maison auprès de centres sans leur pièce
tout ça est très logique voilà une
option qu'ils contrôlent
ici des cases centrale alors pas ici non
mais ensuite
voilà donc le coup voilà c'est donc là
c'est déjà une décision donc ça sera pas
une bande de types indienne ça sera pas
une arme de type grünfeld ça sera une
variante de type soit gambie dames avec
des 5
une rumeur peut-être pour leur
réalisation je pense qu'on peut enlever
notre station parce que ça c'est faux
qu'une petite partie de l'échiquier
donc ça sera quand même plus lisible
bien sûr son arrestation tout à fait
donc ici
effectivement plusieurs options
pour pour les blancs donc après le 6 on
peut développer le cal dans ces trois
ans ce qui est normal mais ça permet
foulée 4 la défense news the beach que
chronique n'a pas l'habitude se dire qu
évidemment il connaît très bien mais il
joue son coup favori qu'est cavaliers 3
le coût pour éviter sa défense nous
devrions maintenant si le foot mais
embêté à tout pour faire échec
eh bien on impose notre fou tout
simplement tout simplement on veut pas
de ce qu'avait dit est très fort en c3
c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre dans ce
genre de système c'est le cas libyen
occupe un poste très intéressant en c3
parce qu'il est derrière les pions ilan
au contrôle des gaz de l'air dans la
liste des questions centrales donc on
veut pas laisser aux noirs l'opportunité
d'aller échanger contre eux d'accord
mais la partie est très très compliqué
très intéressante donc on va passer son
ouverture qu'on a déjà pu commenter
probablement dans notre édition de l'eco
nal dessins et des amis dame voilà on
rentre dans quelque chose qui ressemble
un gambit dame voilà maintenant si
vladimir qu'indique jouquet lycée francs
c'est un grammy dames c'est un gambit
dame s'était un peu des fossettes et
c'est totalement le camp bitam super
classic clay centaines de milliers de
parties très très solide pour moi mes
chroniques et l'écraser et vite et joue
la catalane avec le ce petit coup j'ai 3
voilà ce qu'on appelle la partie catalan
particules peuvent être le fond j'ai 2
où il occupera l'attendent deluna
catalan s'est coincé le joueur catalan
qui aurait qui aurait joué ça en premier
je ne sais pas d'où ça vient non je n'ai
pas la moindre idée de l'historique
la variante mais de tout le monde que
j'ai 3 est un coût que vladimir kramnik
évidemment a déjà joué c'est pas son
coup préféré dans le jeu plutôt caisse
et rend donc peut-être qu'il était
surpris par le choix de wesseling
topalov qui s'est dit je veux jouer une
catalane tranquille en attendant de bien
réviser mon grand vide âme ouais
d'accord pour pour les parties suivantes
pour les participantes est d'accord ça
peut ça peut jouer aussi comme ça avec
un nom de ville à castellane ne sera pas
l'armé principale de la dynamique de
réseau pertes alors où là il ya eu alors
prise ici
normal on prend maintenant le pion
puisque comme on à le donner l'adresse
du fou déjà on va pas reprendre sous peu
avec le fou
donc ça peut être intéressant de prendre
alors c'est à dire que c'est
l'inconvénient majeur de cette catalane
wayne cirque le fou est très bien placé
en g2 mais malheureusement le pion c4 se
retrouve aux prises
voilà donc topalov qui n'est pas du
genre à se dégonfler joue la variante
critique donc une des ventes critique
dépensé cadre il ya deux possibilités
mais celle-là est extrêmement tendue
extrêmement pointus comme on va le voir
tout de suite
alors notez que les banques pourraient
récupérer bien tout de suite évidemment
damas quatre échecs et ensuite on
prendrait le pire mais peut-être que la
dame il serait mal placé sur cette quasi
sion c'est un grand coup qui existe en
effet dans l'est dont la théorie
effectivement les blancs peuvent aller
reprendre ce pion c4 mais s'adonne au
noir beaucoup d'opportunités de
développement rapide puisque on perd du
temps avec la dame donc voir en trois
temps avec la dame et les noirs font
ressortir leurs pièces et pourrait déjà
sortir le fou par exemple pour prendre
et l'échec et ensuite peut-être passé
souffrent de ces six pour contrecarrer
une fougue et 2 alors ça c'est pas le
ceta le plan principal
cilic est sur damas quatre échecs on
joue effectivement plutôt 17 oui ok et
17 d'un procès câble ils essaient de
17,9 en france et 4 à 6 ça c'est une
possibilité pour préparer des 5 es fou
17 et l'autre option sur damas quatre
échelles je crois que c'est cécile
jouable aussi principal d'annoncer
qu'halle berry 17 à 117 ne peux pas
alors que c'est il faut pas toucher
toutes les pièces exportées rien c'est
des traces et la remise en route un drap
la remise en route elle tellement
petites anicroches tactique d'un congrès
ordinaire on disait donc sur un 4 sur
food et c'est tout et c'est peut-être
pas très soudée cette fête que le défaut
était pressée développement peu spécial
il vaut mieux mettre sur la diagonale il
vaut mieux le mettre ici voilà les
possibilités qu'on a montré en tout cas
c'est pas le coup qu'elle choisit
cramique c'est ça le simple mot coûts de
développement fut g2 donc bon mais le
cul rond on s'en occupera plus tard oui
la menace le plan pour récupération
maintenance et cavani e5 locales et qui
vient sur la case aux centrales qui
libère le fond j'ai deux puisque
maintenant la déconne elle sera libre et
le cahier de 5e se prépare à prendre
l'option c4
c'est à dire que le fait qu'on ait
ouvert la diagonale du fou g2 fait qu'il
ya plus de behcet des 5
c'est la torah vite sur la reprise donc
ça c'est le standard ne cède pas prendre
l'option s'éclate avec la dame mais
plutôt avec le québec alors t'as pas le
choisit maintenant le coup logique aussi
de développement avec un gain de temps
échec anormal ont fait échec donc le
coût normal maintenant c'est
d'interposer une pièce évidemment alors
on l'avait dit tout à l'heure il vaut
mieux éviter le cavalier puisqu'avec le
cavalier on en a marre a bien contrôlé
les cases blanches ici sans doute en
kabylie ces trois pour soutenir la force
du fou oui je pense que la réalité voulu
jouer et c3 probablement parce que ça
doit permettre au noir de s'accrocher
aux pions c4
exactement comme ont peut-être des trucs
à base de baies 5 immédiatement on line
le cavalier qui vient dé 5
ça pourrait être des choses comme ça en
tout cas il doit y avoir un problème
tactique pour ne pas jouer ses trois ici
alors fou des deux logiques et la a5
donc on protège le fond tout simplement
et on dit mais si tu me prends et bien
je reprends le bio je commence à avoir
de pions ici assez menaçants vous voyez
en plus au passage on a ouvert la
colonne pour la torah bit vient
seulement se développent et sept tours
peut aussi effectivement avoir une
action si on prend donc c'est logique ça
est très normal donc développement
normal de dames
alors non je ne dirais pas comme ces
développements normal de dan je dirais
simplement urgence pour aller récupérer
ce tube oui parce que trop traîné les
skins topalov menacé ses 6 suivi de
bessens s'étaient installés notion sait
si ces dessins et ensuite on pouvait
toujours s'accrocher pour aller
récupère matériel donc il est temps d'y
aller notons que sur b 5 dans cette
position imaginant b5
voilà des sacs ici il y aurait soit 4,5
lui 2 à 4 soit à 4 directement à 4-4 et
si on revient on peut pas prendre un
événement puisque alors là on aurait
deux paires de gants doublés qui
seraient des faiblesses énorme surtout
j'ai l'impression que ça perdrait du
matériel rapidement cette assurance est
probable que cette heure du matin rapide
rab radio 5 dames qui ont éclaté le flou
des quatre entreprises et après la
menace financer tout cas rio sec
attaquant la tour en même temps faisant
pression sinon qu'ils sont un gros
problème donc il faut jouer ces six dans
cette position faisant pression sur la
casse à 6 après à 4 ont il faut jouer
ces six maintenant
celsis est ici et bien il semblerait que
plus on prend b5 dans un élan de
problème j'en prends mafieux on ne peut
pas reprendre à cause de faucons des
cats alors oui je renvoie là donc c'est
l'astuce faut prendre maintenant
évidemment si on prend ici la tour
empêche la reprise puisque surprend puis
on prend on perdra tout retour et il est
dense devant mais on peut faire un échec
intermédiaire que je me fou construire
chaque intermédiaire alors si on fait
d'abord fou prend un échec
et là est bien content avec le guerrier
f tout simplement avec ce cavalier voilà
hélas le fou empêche le pion de bouger
donc ce pion et par prenable donc là ces
avantages blanc on a réussi à récupérer
tian avec un énorme avantage mans parce
qu'on apprend dans ce système aurait
prononcé qui a donc envoyé du matériel
on a un meilleur développement donc ici
c'est pas acceptable pour topalov donc
il faut faire attention avec quelques
années on reprend toujours ses effectifs
là on aura plusieurs le coût normal
c'est on développe la pièce mais non il
vaut mieux prendre de l'autre celui-là
il prit se développera plus tard en c3
probablement il essaie surtout de
stéphane quelque chose de très très
tactique c'est pour effectuer ce clou
elle sur le classicisme voilà alors dame
ces deux nous donne ces deux urgences
pour vladimir kramnik qui veut récupérer
sanction des cinq n'est pas possible
comme on vient de le voir
donc il faut prendre en d2 c'est ce que
fait topaloff alors c'est pas il faut
profonde et demi des sites de fans en d2
aussi des possibilités s'il ne possède
qu il était vraiment très intéressant
parce que comme on va le voir ce qui va
s'accrocher au pian comme voilà après
cavaliers pro d2 maintenant il peut
jouer des sacs un fou prend et la
chronique donc prend delà de la dame
elles n'ont pas et cavaliers ça qui est
intéressant si les prix du québec et
baie cavaliers voilà qui est le co
logique de développement de maintenance
il y avait 5 et là on protège le pion et
c'est plus du tout pareil parce que
après à 4 on va refaire exactement la
variante stéphane alors imaginons à 4-4
c6 donc ces six pour protéger je prends
b s'incline alors puis on prend mais
c'est là on voit que les fous ne sont
plus là et qu'on a déjà pris de l'autre
cavaliers un conteneur en confection en
carrière 5 est inopérant et on arrive
dans une position compliquée mais où les
blancs d'oeuf se dote parce qu'ils n'ont
qu'un enterrement
il suffit de jouer la tour par exemple
dans la scène yade l'initiative vient
ensuite c'est tout pourra peut-être
venir mais mince et cède protéger encore
une fois ce pion ne nous emballons pas
toujours enfin il faut pas s'emballer
mais la tentation d'appréhension voilà
au blanc maintenant de montrer qu'ils
ont quelque chose comme compensation
tout à fait donc comprendre la dame
voilà donc il a choisi prendra là mais
du coup le soccer n'est pas attaqué
pouvoir donc exactement nuit en nuit
pour kramnik donc la tempe alors choisi
un coup sharp a fait coup double plus
pointus le plus compliqué c'est 6 il
aurait pu se contenter de jouer petit
rock par exemple mais il a décidé de
laisser 6 allée pour s'accrocher au fond
c'est qu'il ya des messages et on va
s'accrocher aux clients pour l'instant
ce qui n'est pas attaqué et si je
regarde le temps mes peintures et en
turquie licra me commence à avoir des
soucis pourra récupérer son pion à noter
que le fou j'ai deux n'est pas si
puissant que ça puisqu'il peut toujours
être bloqué dans lequel edf 6 qui
viendrait sur la quête des 500 cavaliers
diamant ici voilà le sens quel look et
la puissance de fou le cas échéant
ça c'est une idée récurrente dans cette
position c'est à dire que le sujet de il
ya deux solutions pour le contrer soit
on enlève tout ce qui est sur la
diagonale s'était dit on va bouger la
torah vie qui on n'est plus rien sur la
diagonale soit en bouche avec le coup
qu'elle ait des cinq traits alors à 4
alors logique ça c'est logique il veut
prévenir un chronique avec son coulis
prévient la poussée b5
mais il m'a le coréen joo et au fleuret
l'avait prédit cette attaque contre
total of dans l'es5 maintenant assez
tendu comme un oui exact c'est super
tendu tout de suite en héros huitième
coup neuvien coup et on voit que
topaloff
il joue à fond mais il faut noter
stéphane voyez c'est se confirmera au
cours de cette partie de bluff à une
stratégie de match on en parlera
peut-être tout à l'heure mais je crois
qu'il va jamais faire une image allait
fermer
ouais il va jouer toutes les parties à
fond à fond verser les pilotes étaient
rentrés aux castors vivent et c'est
l'épisode de la jme physique au fait là
j'aurai fini il va la jouer physique à
la box in early qui sait que cela
diminuera quelques petits soucis de
quelques petits soucis de santé
ouais que oui peut jouer là dessus et il
sait aussi que lui et bien c'est un
tapis là puisqu'une topaloff est un est
très endurant s'est énormément de sport
et donc il espère que malgré la durée
courte du match et là il va pouvoir
faire la différence
donc ça va être le boxing day 2 dans
l'esprit c'est ça exactement
et donc est ce que le kramnik va pouvoir
tenir le rythme est ce que kramnik à une
condition physique il va on va le
découvrir
parce que c'est sûr que les nuls rapide
jouer enfin favori rapidement joué
en deux coups en 14 trous bon mais c'est
bien ça permet de se reposer mais si
l'adversaire en face veut pas se reposer
comme par exemple typiquement topaloff
eh bien je veux pas on peut pas donc du
coup il va falloir aussi jouer sur le
physique et ça c'est peut-être nouveaux
ça c'est peut-être nouveau parce que
même petit kasparov a démarré sa mais
avant kasparov ont joué uniquement
quasiment qu'aux scientifiques même
fischer s'était pas forcément même si tu
es un joueur venant au fantastique mais
il jouait pas clairement sur 7 sur cette
dimension là kasparov a commencé à jouer
un peu sur ses dimensions la sophistique
aussi un petit peu mais par exemple dans
son match contre kramnik il a aussi fait
une ou deux parties pas forcément super
super combative
en tout cas au moins une bonne morale
elle a fait beaucoup de l'enppi de garry
kasparov et ça c'est peut-être un alors
qu'il était mené au score on sait il
arrivait pas passé il était complètement
débordé peut-être qu'il n'a pas aussi
jouer ce côté-là physique aurait pu
exploser l'adversaire c'est un style
c'est un style extrêmement difficile à
faire c'est à dire que veste ni topalov
dans toutes les parties qu'il ait joué
cette année
et bien il ne fait pas nulles quoi c'est
à dire que la pression il peut être un
peu moins bien où ça peut être super
compliqué il peut faire mieux que jamais
pour l'annuelle toujours il a cherché un
coup pour continuer le combat
une opportunité faire des pièges et
d'autant plus que les règles corses ont
commencé à être diffusés notamment à
sofia le grand tornade sofia que je joue
ou topalov évidemment en tant que
meilleur joueur bulgare où on n'a pas le
droit de faire nul en fait là nul ne
peut être décidée que par l' arbitre en
cliquant jamais tout à fait mais alors
topalov joue toujours c'est parti à fond
à fond à fond alors que la liberté
indique lui accepte annuel régulièrement
alors on revient à la suite de cette
partie punching topalov qui s'accroche à
son point de plus donc ici évidemment
donc l'idée c'était de défendre et avec
à 4 évidemment cramique voulait un peu
attaquées déjà préventivement
ce défenseur ici la ligne est fort c'est
stéphane qui est à dire que la dynamique
n'a qu'une seule solution pour récupérer
qui ont immédiatement la ligne qui l'a
choisi parce que si on laisse un ou deux
coups de plus on ne peut pas jouer un
coup comme cavalier ou 5,6 la question
que je me pose moi tout de suite parce
que ici on fait pression sur le pion
sait s'ils savaient plus fous et
lecavalier mais en même temps menace
maintenant de prendre un b 5 puisque le
fou prendrait la torah 8 alors
exactement
donc là on est dans une situation
le fou j'ai de ce réveil fortement donc
il est temps de l'intercepter et c a pas
d'autre solution puisque l'on peut pas
jouer tour à 7 à cause de cavaliers 38
ans et 6 donc la seule solution s'est
interposé cavaliers de jouer cavalier
des sacs et donc on se bouche or et
voilà ça serait l'idée c'est qu'on
boucherait le fou et le problème reste
entier pour les blancs le courant est
bien protégé exactement quand on a pas
on n'a pas résolu et si on joue à quatre
pour chasser le cavalier celui ci ira en
b4 montrait très bonnes cases cavaliers
gira ici et surtout ce pion de bouche
ralph voilà donc voilà donc il y aura il
y aura soucis donc prise en mécène tout
simplement d'abord ramener comprend
puis on prend le nom de petit point cdn
g51 combine une fois là ce qu'il avait
vu bravo bien je vous traduis donc c'est
c'était là est encore théorique c'était
l'idée de bonnes séquences bien joué
c'était l'idée de dents des deux de la
prise de l'adar évidemment c'est cette
fameuse attaque d'où maintenant on
attaque à la fois le pion g7 et le plan
b 5
heureusement qu'il ya ça évidemment si
les noirs avaient fait le petit rock et
bien l'énorme ici n'aurait plus qu'à
défendre ce pion par exemple part d'un
des six est là il y aurait vraiment gros
souci pour les blancs avec un gros point
de moins que ceux ci me mets là mais là
il va récupérer son pion alors
évidemment pour les noirs ça paraît hors
de propos de laisser ce pion g7 puisque
là le roi noir n'aurait plus de défense
laurent blanc lui il y aurait dans une
très très belle cachette ici la c1
montagne rock complètement inviolable un
coffre-fort est par contre le renoir à
après subir une attaque très
certainement violente donc il faut pas
laisser se faire démolir le rock donc on
va falloir lâcher ce pion oui signes
annoncent stephen
quelque chose s'est il ya une sorte de
transformation qui se passe dans la
position
c'est à dire que les blancs avaient
sorti plus de pièces que les noirs ils
avaient sorti fous cavés vieille dame
beaucoup précédent quand on reviendra
l'impression après dames les deux on
voit que ici on a sorti deux pièces de
plus et on a le trait si on a sorti la
dame et le fou et c'est à nous de jouer
en revanche en un point donc maintenant
il ya une conversion de temps en
matériel oui ce qui est très très
classique très thématiques ainsi donc on
voit que les blancs vont perdre beaucoup
de temps pour aller récupérer le pion
qu'ils en moins et en contrepartie les
noirs vont récupérer leur développement
donc c'est ce qui va se passer dans les
prochains coups d'objets 5 l'attak
double attaque double petit rock très
logique pour défendre l'option de sel et
la faune reprendre plus maintenant pour
reprendre mes cinq enfants ont fait
autant et là on voit que c'est au noir
de jouer maintenant que le nombre de
pièces sorties et équilibrée c'est à
dire qu'il ya un petit rock et 4,6 pour
les noirs cavalière 3f tous les deux
pour les blancs juste la dame blanche
est tombé 5 mais cette eau noire de
jouer et cette dame blanche en dessin
qui est un peu un peu février donc en
fait au niveau 2 du développement
maintenance et les noirs compris
initiative mais des blancs
un avantage puisqu'ils ont le centre ils
ont en plus au centre et les pieds noirs
sont encore un peu faible
les plus inquiets ces quatre sont en
crise quand même alors on voit tout la
suite c'est x 6 x 6 et l'authentic
nouveautés
deux bisquines topaloff il ya une seule
partie avant qui était de choc avec les
blancs contre un joueur russe assez
obscur qui avait joué cavalier à 6 donc
la fois ci c'est la nouveauté de topalov
avec une petite pointe d'ailleurs
stéphane brillé jusque là on a
l'impression que le plus simple étant
prisa qui l'attaqué pas à tour par la
dame et il ya que la dame noire qui
protège mais mais aussi la tour en
transparence alors il ya une pointe
tactique variante très importante et
fondamentale la pointe de ce coup fois
ci c'est que sur dame prompt à 5 alors
on va le voir on va le regarder alors
non il n'a pas joué d'avancé car
justement vladimir kramnik et à jouer
autre chose on va regarder la variante
d'un prend 1,5 et ici le coup très très
fort c'est fou bessette est en fait en
revient avec le fourrage peu fort sur la
tac avec la tour en attaque
la dame et la tour par derrière donc il
faut sa force les changer d'âne sa force
les changer d'âme donc d'un programme de
médias se voir mais qui a l'air qui a
l'air suffisant à me prendre un tour
contours maintenant on sacrifie la dame
un pc crise et c'est momentané enfin
pour ses montagnes est ici parce
qu'alors il faut prendre un tour avec
échec sans doute oui c'est ça la dame
prend tout échec alors non alors pour
garder au passage dan des six mois mais
si on enlève la dame on va on va perdre
ça ensuite ça va tomber
non ce ne sont pas ces défendue par les
fumées alors souvent des investissements
d'amd six ont fait tomber les chèques 3d
2 et là il ya voilà il ya une astuce ses
trois échecs
ces trois chèques qui récupère kicking
la dame en fait tout simplement énorme
sirois pensée 3 on effectue la
fourchette qui a validé sa richesse à la
fourchette ici tac qui attaque rennes
leroy et la dame elle imagine on apprend
ici leur fourchette
voilà il récupère un homme c'est énorme
et sinon il ne croit pas beaucoup de
travaux s'est classée 2e tour prend b2
sur moi c'est 2 fois 4
il faut être encore plus grave fou et
quatre échecs est fréquent puisque là
s'il aura bougé bien on prendrait avec
échec et ensuite on prendra des mêmes
thèmes suroît trompions c3 il y avait
des cinq voire sept ans il y aurait
fourchette
voilà c'est énorme donc en fait tout a
été calculé n'était que d'un v6 ne
marche pas c'est le défi lancé le fan
qui ont ces quatre individus
le petit poucet 3 qui est un poison
certains c'est un vrai poison en tout
cas c'est une belle pour une banque si
on revient de coups avant alors si on
revient voilà la dame étant de huit dont
qui s'y méprendre la tournée objets
trouvés d'un proto avec l'échec mais
qu'elle est riche en disant puisque il
ya un cursus pour les blancs ici après
avoit prend entre un petit rock food
donc il faut protéger le cavalier on
voit le tyran qu'ils étaient forcés ou
rendez de la limite mais s'il veut des
déchets possible c'était embêtant donc
au petit rock est maintenant dans cette
position le simple coûte aura deux
attaques l'option b 2 qui donne une
position extrêmement équilibrée puisque
on voit que les noirs on a tombé
voilà le cuir retombe et les noirs
tiennent au centre on voit que le fourbe
et cette éclaircie se tiennent bien les
cases de 4 et d5 le pion c4 va être
passée il est faible mais il va être
passée donc ici c'est une position
équilibrée
alors bon ça c'est lié à la pointe du
couteau à 6,2 des sprinteurs voilà c'est
la poignée coup fois ci c'est c'est
pourquoi kravica joué le coup dames à 4
et qui n'a pas pris ici il a senti venir
le souffre et le vent notre ami cramique
il a dû calculer tout ça évidemment où
il a calculé les il a réfléchi assez
longtemps pour jouer damas quatre ici
c'est dix bombes à la chine conserve
quand même mon avantage ne lui permet
pas je ne permettait à winter palace
d'entrer en finale je vais jouer
probablement qu'elle va de la simple à
préparer qui va de 5
je vais également c'est de récupérer le
pion c4 passé à chaque qui est bd donc
voilà tout ce que s'est dit ici
vesselina d'hier par annick goutal à 4
alors ensuite d'un v6 sont donc logiques
un développement d'apps une classe elle
pas puisque l attaque ici un pion à rire
et qui en plus est contrôlée dans les
cases d'avancé sont contrôlés par un
pion prévu
la défendre ça fait la pression puis
d'un v6 sakho extrêmement logique
effectivement qui met la pression et
bien mort sont pour des cas petit
développe une pièce qui attaquent le
plan b ils travaillent type de fonction
kramnik choisi de ne même pas prêté
attention à ce pion et donkey rock où il
n'y avait pas vraiment de défense
satisfaisante du psion mais de toute
façon si tu étais trop haut trop il y
avait des massifs il y avait des ennuis
tactique parce que les noms sont sortis
beaucoup de pièces et ça risque
d'exploser d'une seconde à l'autre donc
ici il était temps pour venir chronique
de mettre le roi doit hélas topalov se
sert un pouf et voilà c'est son truc lui
y voit des pions lui prend il ne refuse
jamais ce genre de proposition voilà
donc il prend le pian et la tête le qe2
au passage s'accrocher car c'est typique
le genre de variantes mais borderline il
faut il faut il faut démontrer qu'on a
raison que ce soit du côté blanc écoute
et noir alors c'est borderline pourquoi
pas ce que l'on voit quand même qu'il ya
toujours un risque énorme
la tour habitaient les pas défendue si
lecavalier bouge la tour est attaqué
donc ça donne des thèmes tactique
s'adapter at il faut voir également que
si on laisse elle est le long terme et
va les pions vont commencer à avancer
les pions aux quatre des cinq on va se
faire piquer nos faiblesses
donc ici il ya gros danger sur le long
terme pour une province ni topaloff
c'est extrêmement content relativement
tendue et il va quand même chercher au
tube est à noter que la dame occuperait
un poste assez important ici l attaque
l'option 2 met la pression sur la tour
un petit peu et attaque l'option des 4
égalant qui est défendue pour le mans
mais la dame occupe un poste très
intéressant qui malheureusement n'est
pas très sécurisé puisque bien dans le
camp des bornes
oui c'est vrai tout à fait un mois il ya
un endroit où il peut ce rachat s'est
assez vite par exemple par trois de mes
chroniques choisi tout simplement un
développement logique avec trait sans
doute wall street grâce à une menace
assez nette qui est donc tour à b1 suivi
de tours fc 1 qui gagne à la pompe on
peut montrer imaginant que je vous parle
est un peu logique dans l'europe en
maintenant le vrai problème puisqu'il y
aurait tour à bellaing par exemple et la
dame est attaqué et surnomme c3 c3 qui
saurait être c'est la surprise
y'a plus de 4 elle est politique on voit
le credo là le tour de la boutique il ya
des contrôles et ne résoudrait pas les
lames il a un il a dit l'un la tour est
défendue et puis là il ya plus de cases
la ses protégés par le cavalier elles
seraient prises dame là ses protégés pas
le cas mais aussi les seraient prises
un enfermement la sphère son chéquier s
ils assez rare quand même très joli et
ennuyeux alors donc il faut faire
attention et donc c'est pourquoi topalov
laisse pas kramnik respirer en jouant au
foot b5 très joli coup attaque la dame
et en plus on voit bien que cette dame à
parvenir en d1 ce qui serait un peu
passif est bien de doit proposer un
échange il faut échanger la dame quoi
très certainement
alors si on était contraint de changer
d'homme ça posera un problème c'est à
dire si le seul coup était damas trois
c'est la menace serait vraiment un
problème évidemment vladimir kramnik a
vu une réponse on parade à ce qu'on fout
les saints qui a l'air très très fort
puisque comme tu l'as dit stéphane
attaque la dame qui n'a pas beaucoup de
cases en plus on vient de défendre le
plan à cinq ans à plus de 2.5
puisqu'elle le fou d'intercepteurs plus
la tour sur cette case donc ici gros
problème mais heureusement vladimir
kramnik à vue il a joué cavalli
préemption c4 contre attaque et point
tactiques pas simple parce que
alors imaginez un exode des deux
imaginez un coup qu'on me daems et
roanne ont fait un mort alors qu'un faux
gardes fous voilà le point de ces que la
dame est en train de défendre le faut
ils font partager du faux évidemment
donc pas le choix entre autres options
quand vous avez comme ça la dame de
votre adversaire qui attaque et votre
dame qui attaque et le réflexe est
donnée la dame avec un coup intervenir
sur une grosse pièce est donc le réflexe
serait de jouer d'un point en cinq
éditions çà marche pas mais ça ne marche
pas parce qu'il fait justement reprendre
avec la dame sinon ça gagnera une
qualité c'est à dire que si la réponse
était d'un premier 5
la pièce attaquer ouais ou tout reprend
d'amont jour il faut compter cinq ans
gagne en qualité tout à fait donc ici ça
ne marche pas simplement parce que la
dame qui peut venir reprend donc le
réflexe classique qui est de donner sa
dame contre les pièces majeures ne
marche pas donc ici et voir avec les
chèques ou alors il cache avec voilà
encore là la terre mieux défendu donc le
fousseret prix à la fin donc l'état soit
pas l'échec donc ya pas le choix et donc
topalov choisi d'échanger les dames par
fu panda mme way cavalli prendre voilà
ça c'était séquence force et maintenant
on arrive dans une position compliquée
ou veselin topalov doit choisir où il va
replacer son fou si on peut faire des
remarques générales sur cette position
c'est que le pion à est passé donc c'est
un pion passé donc ça fout la réunion
puisqu'ils menace de pousser 20 à long
terme il ira à dame
à long terme il peut menacer de farnham
les blancs maintenant e.on le centre
s'est inversée en deux pions contraint
au centre tout à fait donc ça c'est
l'avantagé des blancs ils ont des pièces
mieux développer c'est à dire que ils
ont sorti de la zone de ce local et noir
est encore bien 8 menace cavani aux 5
même si le cavaly b2 et pas forcément le
diavel et b ne vais pas au top pour un
sens mais il bloque le pion à cannes
et puis ils attaquent le feu qui peut
ressortir en ces cas depuis 2006 il peut
être assez pénible
donc ici une position complètement
balancer une espagne topalov doit
choisir entre deux coups un fou des cinq
qui attaquera tu m'as donné votre
appétit qui sait si ce qui comptera ce
fou j'étais alors ces attaques de fou
c est aussi ça domine le carrier sa
domine un peu le cavalier petit peu
c'est à dire qu'il finira comblé par
s'en sortir
oui il finira par s'en sortir il va
sortir aura 4 mai mais en tout cas il
est il est sous contrôle il peut pas il
peut pas s'échapper ou faire des choses
non prévu donc en regardant cette
position en direct stephen gt gt
vraiment pas sûr de l'évaluation pour
moi c'est une position très très
équilibré alors quand même pour les
blancs on a quand même noté il ya quand
même le contrôle du centre on va dire
que là il ya le fou comme 1 qui va
contrôler par transparence et quasi
blanche les cases noires sont contrôlés
dont elles paraissent contrôle du centre
mais un échange évidemment il ya ceux
qui ont passé quelques en même une vraie
plaie et qui va donc il va falloir
s'occuper sérieusement foulée sages
attaquent le qe2 voilà donc qui en coule
au gîte de développement pour kramnik
pour déployer ses pièces qu'elle ait à
la fois un contrôle un petit peu les
cases de sortie ce qu'avait dit par
exemple et aussi avait tout de suite
gagne du temps et sur le tour il faut
que la tour réagissent dans un coup
logique de topalov je pense pour la
suite c'est tour à sept petits coups
simplement pour éviter le fou à la
tourette attaquer il faut bouger la tour
pouvait rien interposés notons que
l'interception qui est des cinq ici ne
faisait plus vraiment de sens oui il y
avait des cinq avant de jouer trois
recettes puisque maintenant ça ça laisse
vladimir kramnik j'avais eu quatre
dessins il faut le signaler
alors d'abord bouger des traits fins
nationales jouer la tour et ensuite on
prépare le cas depuis des cinq avec un
pion passé centrale il sera bien plus
pénible à gérer que l'option à cinq
équipes ont gardé la variante parise ans
peut-être surtout rien ici il y aurait
peut-être fou prend le 2 c'est quand
même embêtant c'est jouable aussi bien
celle ci je vois le mais peut-être tout
cas peut-être plus simplement de retour
ici
si possible avec l'idée de dieu car le
cas depuis des 5-6 position tendu c'est
en toi ça a été un coup il ya plusieurs
fossiles
c'est aussi une histoire de style
de calcul mon de faut que les joueurs
aussi à l'effondrement de la valeur
intrinsèque des positions et joueront
des styles il ya des pressions qu'ils
préfèrent et des pièces qui préfère
manier kasparov disaient qu'ils
préfèrent les fous comme 90% des forges
heures c'est vrai qu'elles font jour fou
ça c'est clair mais après il ya certains
types de position je rappelle un livre
sur fisher notamment qui expliqué qu'ils
montrent est typiquement les positions
le type de puce ion d'une structure de
pions en tout cas que l'affectionné
qu'affectionnait bobby fischer oui mais
bobby fischer est connu pour être un
joueur universelle capable de jouer
n'importe quel type de position dans
n'importe quel état d'esprit donc pour
le bien pour les nuls de jeu de toujours
chercher le meilleur coup donc peut pas
vraiment parler de style pour bobby
fischer puisqu'ils jouer indifféremment
les coûts dans toutes les pressions en
revanche les salaires les d'un style
topalov ça c'est certain on vraiment
parler nos cités topaloff est d'un style
cramique topalov c'est tout pour
l'initiative tout pour l'attaqué et le
style krainik c'est le rouleau
compresseur les pièces qui sortent le
prise du centre la paire de fous tous
les petits la mise en valeur de micro
avantage voilà exactement à la sig
bastarache c'est ça hein le fameux
précepteur germany avait commencé ça
donc il ya deux styles qui s'affrontent
mais ici on est dans une position où
c'est pas nécessairement une question
style c'est plutôt une question de
calcul et jour calculait troublé
beaucoup et les jeux alors fou et f3
défense du pion mais deux on défend le
pion et de tout simplement et puis le
fou est bien ici aussi contrôler un peu
plus de cases sur ce côté là bon ça sert
pas à grand chose d'unique
mais c'est une sortie de sa laisse un
peu d'air ou aura aussi la rôdé fois
plus brillant des fragilités les
autodéfenses option donc y'a pas d'autre
idée que défend spécial parce qu'il
voulait pas mettre ses atouts en main
sans doute il vole il veut il veut la
mettre en scène voulait pas immobiliser
une tour pour défendre ap topalov
clasico 6 or ces pièces voilà la
dernière pièce qui jouait pas un
classique double avantage pour ce coup
qui manie b17 le premier c'est
effectivement de libérer la tour eiffel
qui maintenant on va pouvoir aller soit
sur la case à 8 soit sur la classe c 8
enfin vous pouvez déjà égalé d'enfin ça
libère un peu la tour et l'autre
avantage c'est que ça attaque
directement la pièce blanche la plus
forte
qui est donc ce qu'est vallejo 5 on
menace de l'échangé menace clairement
qu'elle allait prendre 5 puisque la
pression
accueil des 5 est maintenant bel
avantage pour topalov dans le cas où on
arrive justement à éliminer un peu la
force centrale donc ici un coût
extrêmement logique on va faire un peu
le ménage parmi ses flèches qui a 17 le
coût normal donc double avantage permet
de sortir des trois fuites et permet
d'essayer dé changer la pièce forte des
dons voile afin de lui un petit problème
de micro donc tout de suite après
kramnik donc maintenant lui a déployé sa
pièce aussi qui est mal placée ce
cavalli b2 donc voilà c'est un manège de
pièces vraiment développement derniers
développements et si pourtant pas leur
coûter un contenu un signal cavaliers
bon qu'est ce qu'ils en ont la vie de
l'autre car il parle en cavalier et je
sais que c'est un choix il veut pas
laisser les changes des cavaliers des
places et l'autre veut continuer à
garder son cavalier b2 pour le moment
pour la thèse à 4 on y retrouve cette
case à case il évite les changes des
cavaliers dont qui remet son cas ici ils
attaquent le pion à servir donc en fait
ces deux cavaliers se défendre
mutuellement et contrôler les deux cases
duction passé noir donc pour le moment
une formation logique de la part de la
nuit par des cons on notera que topalov
ne peut pas jouer tout rabbit
puisqu'elle serait temps prise par le
fou tout à fait impossible de défendre
le pion par ce moyen là donc veselin
topalov et objet de trouver des moyens
détournés maintenant de défendre son pur
à 5 alors tournés 8
logique la dernière pièce qui jouait pas
là aussi alors il faut signaler donc
évidemment lapointe qui l'est ce qui se
passerait sur cavaliers campion à 5
alors que se passera-t-il sur cavani
30-5 donc tout simplement plus tard ici
voilà il ya foule pour eux deux qui est
tout à fait normal qui est donc une
sorte de découverte dans la tourbe ebit
qui va se réveiller pour les prendre le
tuer la b2 hélas cette tour ensuite
prendre un cavalier enfin voilà on a
senti qu'on vous notons qu'on a perdu
notre fou contre un cavalier après fou
qu'on fout tour quand cavaliers on prend
donc en baisse de temps prendrait donc
on a donné notre fou mais en revanche on
a cassé complètement la structure
d'action blanche maintenant que les plus
curieux le pion des se retrouve isolé la
position des noirs extrêmement solide
que toi un petit avantage noir dans
cette position tout cas une potion
christian topalov se serait régalé à
jouer ou alors il aura fait nul tout du
moins les autres options donc ici
vladimir kramnik qui joue pour le gain
tout simplement on ne veut pas permettre
des changes
donc il fait 3 bien tord afp un
classique aussi elle a lu la motion
il réitère la menace de prendre le pion
à sens on va appeler de joueur met en
jeu toute leur dernière pièce qui jouait
pas la passion de façon très très clair
et très simple s'il ya finalement on
essayait un problème pour leslie topalov
stéphane ces clôtures à 5 est très très
dur à défendre c'est un jeu à 4 1 en
étant prise puisque le travail illégal
c'est sans doute le l'option de jouer à
4 ne marche pas non plus alors imaginons
donc ici je crois qu'on dit qu'elle va
dire protéger avec des points là pour
protéger
oui il pourrait y avoir calé six
attaques le v5 menace aussi qu'ils
avaient propension à quatre noms ne mena
stocker pour incarner non puisque la
tour ici est défendu de kwanzas juste de
prendre par le cavalier on menace de
prendre les 5 et 12 pouces et six
manades prendre ici par exemple
imaginons que les noirs jouent un coup
bidon alors dans ce cas là on pourrait
peut-être prendre ici et surtout reprend
et poussé poussé 6 avec un ennui avec
prolonge le gain du jour à quatre après
une éruption en restructurant suite
d'une mère général c'est pas rien est
évident les noirs ont beaucoup beaucoup
de jeunes mais topalov a trouvé un coup
excellence et le coup j'ai 5
alors on le voit tout de suite donc j'ai
5 voilà donc ça c'est un coup à la
topalov agressifs ont créé la fameuse
fenêtre dont on a besoin pour libérer le
roi des éventuels mat du couloir
ça ça peut toujours servir et là il a
trouvé une fois agressif en fait l'idée
de ce coup j'ai cinq donc effectivement
stéphane c'est de prendre de l'espace de
donner une case pour leurs droits comme
tu viens de le signaler aussi peut-être
de manas dauger quatre qui déplace le
fouest roi et qui réitérera tous les
problèmes qu'on a sur le qe2 voilà voilà
le l'idée de g5 donc maintenant sûr
qu'avec on a 5 et bien évidemment c'est
très simple on joue g4 et on soit calé
devant être un bon jour est tout
simplement g4 donc le cavalier ici
protège le pian le foot doit bouger et
ensuite c'est le pion et 2 qui sera en
prise voilà et là on aurait la pose de
la belle position avec l'option isolé
pour les blancs une défense indirects
une des forces avaient arrêté ça donc la
chronique je voyais soit et je pars donc
choisi un coup simple 3 voilà il se
débarrasse définitivement du problème du
pion eux deux il ya plus de dégâts que
tu as eu le problème résolu les coups
s'enchaînent ici topalov qui joue g4
toujours très content la natation ou
bien logique food et 1 on garde une
chronique se dit mais finalement ce fou
maintenant il agit plus trop sur cette
colonne sur cette diagonale pendant les
gardes à nice ont cure à 4 sur purgé
quatre partants immobilisant du coup le
cavalière s'est souvent l'idée comme ça
quand on est attaqué garder un oeil sur
le sur le pur avant c'est donc là donc
exploitation immédiate de veselin
topalov avec le couscous et 6 lui il
prend position cette grande diagonale
il prend les gonades qui a été lâché
lâché par le fou voilà ici
notons que l'ennui de 7 on peut toujours
pas prendre le pion à 5 stéphane
puisqu'il ferait cavalier prend 1,5
il y aurait le couffo aux quatre alors
sur calais prend 1,5 eh bien oui vous
aux 4 qui fait très mal
un tacle à tête la tour et si la tour
bouge bien le québec où est on prêt
imaginons tour c'est un seul coup le
cavalier temps prise voilà tout
simplement
donc il faut attaquer le défenseur donc
faut faire attention d'ailleurs c'est la
menace
peut-être un jour il faut le 4 x 4 c'est
un coût qui va prendre toutes les cases
blanches qui veut bon les pions blancs
nathan sont moins mobiles donc tout se
joue sur ce pion à 5 est ce que force ou
faiblesse c'est toujours le débat quand
on est un pion passait bien est ce qu'il
va être fort ou est ce qu'il va être
faible rien n'est clair alors fois eu
qu'à coincer un tour c'est un très
logique on met la tour en vis-à-vis du
fou on prévient le couffo aux 4 c'est
dire que la tour ne sera plus aux prises
comme un gros quart d'heure vis-à-vis du
fou donc la menace peut être carrément
la série pro bono ce sont d'autres
câbles hypron 1,5
peut-être peut-être parce qu'attention
quand même cavalier prix à la fin mais
le foot c'est si ce qui est bien la
fougue et j'avoue qu'il sera attaqué
tout à fait fou aux 4 donc là il enlève
beaucoup de cette attaque est là car il
ya quatre donc sa c2 cramique déclarer
les biens jolis l'ain alors me tout sur
la quatrième rangée
notons un petit replacements de ce
cavalier qui était en b2 qui a fait son
travail qui a bloqué le pion pendant un
petit bout de temps et qui maintenant
ressort à 4 avec l'idée d'aller en c3
c'est une des idées de vladimir kramnik
c'est johnny et ses 3 voilà on l'a dit
depuis le début
les cas ces trois est fondamental pour
le cavalier parce que c'est là qu'on
contrôle des caisses centrales
importante
les quatre banques centrales en
centrales ils contrôleraient ils
contrôleraient ensuite c'est qu'elle l'a
d'où l'idée de ce cas il ya 4 c'est sûr
que ce cavalier des deux n'était pas
joli un sac à malices ils n'étaient pas
activées c'est un peu le concept de la
paix si l'on voulait jouer tout de suite
tout à l'heure mais chronique a choisi
de le faire en plusieurs temps d'être la
position est quand même toujours
équilibré
avec art une meilleure structure de
pions pour kramnik même si elle n'est
pas mobile mais sur le long terme
il ya quand même aussi ce problème là ce
soutien qui est passé sont arrivées
toutes les pièces la finale serait
probablement favorable ces mots avec
toutes les pièces étaient en guerre tout
les rois oui là bas c'est favorable pour
le show pas s'éloigner normal assez
favorable a priori pour ce pion là mais
bon on anticipe un petit peu comme c'est
valable non mais c'est pour ces
pourparlers de long terme donc très très
long terme par exemple ici alors tombé
car d4 et vite qu'avec des c3 puisque
maintenant le cas et c'est qu'il serait
temps prise si on voulait évidemment le
cas à lille et en prix voilà simplement
donc ici choisi de jouer ce callian des
six attaquants le fou donc là c'est
vraiment des manoeuvres on arrive dans
une séquence extrêmement compliqué de la
partie avec le quai vallet qui vient des
six les cavaliers qui saute un peu sur
toutes les cases le pion à 5 et pu
attaquer on s'éloigne de la taille du
pur à saint fons contrôlons le bloc on
sait pas trop face au passage la partie
est assez obscur est assez délicat à
commenter parce que les pièces vont un
peu partout et c'est pas facile là
topalov choisi de proposer un échange de
foule tout ça mais n'a pas peur parce
qu'il va se dire soutien si je prendrai
le plan ce plan là ça sera très très
fort puisqu'il va tenir en respect le
roi blanc
donc c'est une espèce de clou planté
dans le cercueil des bd des blancs la
fidèle à son style topalov en met
partout
après faut pour un f3 g pour un f3 il ya
deux faiblesses pour topalov le climat
astral pion à 5 faiblesse faiblesse mais
si on donne trois coups au blanc dans
les blancs jouent à l'étranger qu'à 3h
de roger 3h 3 à 4 ans âge de leur âge et
rend à rome l'ambiance n'a pas mangé de
noël sera donc ça c'est faible mais en
même temps ou comme les deux qui sont
faibles il sait pas trop sur lequel
jouer
mercredi que le cas l'attaqué en premier
et comment donc ici un sans faute et
effectivement en fait c'est aussi deux
avantages c'est que tu vois il faut
toujours se mettre d aller à damer le
pion bref il enfin le roi blanc dans une
sorte de cage donc position et que la
position est devenue extrêmement
compliqué car ils s'évitent attaque la
tour ici et des fois peut faire deux
peut-être des échecs intéressant
toujours n'y a rien à manger il n'y a
pas de fourchette
mais s'il y avait des pièces ici damman
ça serait quasiment bien il ya tout de
suite imaginons que l'autre tour kg tour
avait été dans la part d'alpha rage une
erreur qu'on pourra vite il a joué tous
ravis donc tour à 8 logique tout
simplement un terrier la cara lien cet
échec
voilà il se replace vladimir kramnik il
ramène ses pièces on sait pas trop où il
va mais justement c'est pour ça que je
disais que ce passage est assez obscures
le roi qui se replacent très bien donc à
vis de cet échec crois j'essais cavalli
c6 maintenant ça c'est une thèse
intéressante la casse et 6 passes que
attaque la tour attaque le pion à 500
l'attaqué mais mais la pression sera
plus 1,5 et en autant de temps en temps
ce qui est des sept donc les béances
replaçant 2 5i on va prendre ce point
seront donc il a trouvé une case pas mal
pour son cavalier qui manoeuvre un peu
longue et un peu fastidieuse mais
finalement une arrivée à quelque chose
qui est un peu évident alors là on va
rentrer on est dans une très fin de
partie on est toujours en sort du jeu
encore parce que les pièces raréfient et
on va rentrer maintenant après on va
voir que jusqu'au bout
topalov va chercher des chances de bien
et est encore là toujours avec ces
manoeuvres là et là on va rentrer c'est
pas facile a commenté on va dire l'eau
s'écouler cookies et compte il suffit de
les couler co2 légère compression des
coûts qui suivent aussi ça reste des
passades tapptic où les adversaires
finalement essaie de placer au mieux
leur pièce c'est ça le combat il est là
il sait trouver les meilleurs les
meilleures places quand même pour leur
pièce c'est de mettre la pression
maximale sur l'adversaire ça c'est un
des problèmes est maintenant celle à
cette tactique également c'est la crise
et une tactique c'est tactique
donc c est ce qu'on va réussir qu'on le
pion est ce qu'on va réussir à faire
échec profiter le droit blanc faible bon
tout est compliqué c'est une finale
compliqué finale d'attac
alors voyons comment ça se déroule donc
avalé ses cinq titres à nîmes propose un
échange quelques cavaliers
évidemment ça se ressente pas une bonne
opération pour les noirs de prendre
parce qu'on pourrait prendre sans doute
du pion secret en gros plan passez moi
il serait déjà très avancé et surtout on
voit que après le cavalier blanc revient
sur la case des 4,60 nouvellement
libérés ou la case aux cinq portes
normalement le heureux pour le club
on va prendre ça pue rend plus serein et
sûr et on va travailler va laisser ça va
ça va être ce n'est pas une option de
jouer qui à l'époque avait donc une tour
derrière ça va ça va perturber les tours
adverses
alors il n'en comprend pas et on joue
autour des 5 tours b 5 a lancé cinq
missiles tombent et simple photo call of
cookie des fonds le pion à saint gilles
à to'ata en fait de simples ont été
empreintes simplement donc hélas le
fameux tu parlais page 3 il veut jouer
sans doute j4 orages deux mois j'ai
trente et un de plus voilà exactement
cavalli prend tout reprend et oui hélas
il n'a pas joué ton tour oui toujours
il aurait pu jouer toronto exactement il
a joué tous les deux toujours actif sur
la deuxième rangée est atteint car
notamment ce pion les abonnés manger
très important pour les tours 2e où se
tient un coup de crosse et un coût
extrêmement responsable de la part
d'autres pilotes parce qu'il donne son
coup droit semble quand même au passage
il donne un pion quoi ils savent
champions dans une finale donc c'est pas
c'est pas un concept évident bon alors
il a vu qu'il avait une force et comme
on va le voir dans la partie mais il a
donné son nom il a donné son meilleur
ami lan très forte y en a ici qui fait
pression sur le roi albert qui peut pas
bouger et on va voir que les blancs vont
pas pouvoir quitter la défense de ce
plan là et ça va être très difficile
pour eux tour échec
regardons tout de suite la suite du
rejet synchro h600 ça c'est un petit
coup je dirais
de déstabilisation déstabilisation par
le roi n'ayant f6 les décalant que son
droit donc alors ici en russie ce normal
tourcoing s'est ensuite maintenant il
prend la progression à 5
une sorte de pendule l échange de taux
par un fil a pas peur et donc on rentre
maintenant dans une vraie finale
classique avec un pion de moyens alors
nous ton stéphane qu' il fallait pas se
tromper il fallait pas jouer tourcoing
sonne à huy non on pouvait le faire en
fait ça revenait à peu problème après
tourbe est un échec
rouage deux tours f2 encore une fois
hélas le pion est attaqué on peux pas le
défendre jour là toujours la possibilité
d'une force et voilà il faut revenir il
ya nulle a forcé par les pétitions
exactement à noter que ce n'était pas
lost ou encore tenté de jouer comme on
va le voir dans la partie mais là c'est
on va assister un temps de la partie
après qu'ils éprouvent à 51.5 qui avait
dit aux 4,4 et larissa yale l'option l2
est attaqué le couple voilà c'est la
difficulté et il ya une grosse
difficulté il est à coup sûr les grands
gagnants sont bien dessinés l'option est
attaqué à noter la hague à une grosse
pression noir à noter que c'est l'unique
faiblesse des blancs c'est à dire que
une fois qu'on défonce conception défend
tout le reste et c'est vrai donc il ya
que ça et le pion est défendue par le
roi est ici cramique rajoute une défense
tout répond ouais mais c'est très passif
c'est très passif met donc en fait il
faut il faut dire que les noirs ne
risque rien dans cette position après
qu'ils aient des deux mais peut-être que
les blancs tour c'est un cavalier ou
quatre on revient et vladimir kramnik
est obligé de revenir également
voilà donc là il aurait pu faire un nul
topalov mans là il va tout à fait là nul
avec une nulle finalement but combat ne
doit pas dire kramnik été non plus on
peut pas dire qu'il était sous pression
particulièrement il a
il a quand même tenu la partie
correctement bon tu en parles pas trouvé
ddd joli coup intéressant et dynamique
c'est quand même oui c'est le dernier
des derniers des joueurs qui est censé
se faire exploser dans toutes les
parties visées clairement la dynamique a
mis la pression également topalov aussi
donc on arrive dans une finale avec un
équilibre dynamique un pion de plus pour
ranimer chronique mais nous le forcer
pour topalov à ce fameux pions ici qui
immobilise complètement le roi adverse
notamment avec l'aide de ce pion sauf un
pion donc très bien vu positionnement en
avoir fait cet échange de fou oui avec à
noter que qui est le livre chronique il
ya peu dans les choux
il ya de se qualifier un petit peu qui
peut bouger a finalement bien que lui
mais si ce qui importe c'est que palop
décide de jouer cette position donc
c'est encore incroyable puisque pour
l'instant il n'y a rien en essence 1,6
ça n'a pas d'incidence et crâne et n'a
pas le choix il n'a qu'une seule pièce
qui peut bouger c'est aux cavaliers donc
il va falloir qu'ils trouvent des goûts
et ils en trouvent un facilement qu'elle
nécessite on a préféré trouver d'autres
claqué ces six là on va regarder un
attaque de la tour voilà au rouge là on
reviendra port du voile a pris du temps
pour démontrer qu'on peut faire mais
aussi contre feignies quand je veux t'en
sors je vais je vais réfléchir mes
chroniques dit oui mais moi aussi je
fais du projet 6 pour topalov car il est
des huit attaques 19.6 bon cette attaque
comme ça un petit tentative de
déstabilisation et bien topalov choisi
de défendre aussi c'est donc il ya plus
la taille des deux mais maintenant le
cavalier de
de belote rami qu'on débite est enfermé
donc la g league choisi de sortir sa
tour ici évidemment pour permettre son
cavalier notamment de ressortir et
d'avoir des cases puisqu'on voit que
toutes les autres cases ou s'ils sont
prises tout est pris soin par la tour
ici soit par le roi donc il y aurait que
cette case safe ici sont cette case là
donc auxonnais topalov qui joue toujours
maintenant qu'ils envoient le pion h
il avoua qu'il envoie le bois ils
essaient de il essaie de créer des
soucis aux blancs et la bannière pour
cent dans le coup pour gagner un premier
cas pas de coup là il n'y a pas de cours
qu'est ce qu'il peut faire et il
pourrait pas jouer le tour c'est 2 par
exemple
alors pour celle de stéphane ya un
énorme problème n'a pas tort ces deux là
regardez on va être content ours et 2
c'est ici il ya une possibilité donc
tourbe et un chien crache 2 maintenant
il ya du tour à tour f1 qui est possible
je sais pas si on le fait tout de suite
parce que tu as aussi cette emprise ou
si on le prépare un salaire forte un
salaire assez fort à fort parce que ce
pion être très fort quand même
après les blancs vont pas pouvoir le
prendre on va peut-être même échangé les
tours c'est sûr que les blancs en chine
qui ont passé mais ça peut encore être
défendus mais dont la défense
ici la structure de des blancs la base
la structure dépensera sera aura sauté
oui c'est en fait longuement fait le
gros problème dans cette position
stephen après tout f-16 ont fait qu'il
ait pris le 6e rang avec les cavaliers
n'ont pas à être là tout est au
programme
cavalière revient aux quatre missions
avancent moins de 2 soutenu par ce
cavalier mouais la tour se déplacer en
suisse alain geiger perdre une tour
garda pour défendre c'est celle ci
aurait donc il faut pas donner du rêve
est donc suracheté inquiets bien
vladimir kramnik n'a pas d'autre choix
que de rester sur la première rangée
torah il sait pas trop ce qu'il fait et
au balo fait continuer d'envoi h4 ça
c'est
l'ofs le psychopathe qui donne un
deuxième pion au final alors que je
connais le proverbe stefania pas de
cette fille de poèmes et les donne pas
c'est pas vraiment donné parce que c'est
ric 2 kg ont passé fait depuis doublé
sur la colonne h c'est extrêmement
faible c'est vrai qu'il récupère et
facilement donc on prend h4 il y avait
aussi g4 qui était possible mais la
position était voilà selon tous les
experts l'opposition tout eu le courage
c'est inconvenant menace de prendre
l'option que tu as h 40 donc là
maintenant kramnik joue le couteau à
deux il n'ya plus les ménages dont tu
parlais et loi puisque le temps il fera
à rouage de et en cas de toux reste un
garage et rend enfin il peut y avoir
enregistré dans la déranger 3 il peut
pas y avoir dérogé trois pattes mais
effectivement dans la suite de la partie
aux caisses qui va déprendre maintenant
urgent rejetteront c'est à dire la
viande qu'on a signalé machine en
imaginant échec h 2 maintenant pour être
là qui est pro 6 est là c'est plus du
tout la même histoire parce qu'après les
problèmes de maintenance de ses
chaleureux devait s'échapper par exemple
ou alors on peut enfin tout cas yagg on
n'est pas plus à revenir quand tout à
l'heure où il est violet pu empêcher la
mort
oui et puis il faut dire aussi au
passage que ouais c'est pas du tout la
même chose
c'est pas la même chose alors ici donc
tu en prends h4 a choisi de jouer
donc oui le roi est remonté voilà
rouages deux là topalov maintenant
d'appeler le plan vraiment il jouera à
justin qui revient que roy l'un des
seuls 10 des topalov c'est de transférer
la tour sur la colonne des transferts
cette tour sur l'école ici un disque il
y aura un échec à tanger le vainqueur
c'est ce que la sonatt donc c'est la
seule idée de topalov mais pour le
moment ça ne marche pas parce qu attend
voilà c'est si par exemple topalov joue
un coup comme tomber vite tomber 8
voilà en fait qui est pro 6 est
maintenant surtout rejet lite on dispose
de cavalieri 4 sur toute la rive et 4 et
des analyses qui retient la femme à ce
qui est très important à l'intranet donc
là topalov va essayer de ruser pendant
quelques coups pour essayer de tourner
cette source la colonne j'étais comme un
plan qui est très très menaçant donc
pour ces deux races six tours à deux
donc gravitas temps on avec c'est nul
roger 6 c'est toujours nulle topalov
continue à jouer tour ces deux cas on
sait pas trop où il en est
granit à tanger même en jouant rien puis
topalov il continue à gagner mais c'est
de gagner non qui désire
j'avais les genoux il a défendu sont
plus aussi saisie c'est fmi a défendu
eric leroy là et maintenant il faut
tourner sa rivale peut-être arriver à
passer là des fois j'étais resté c'est
ce qu'il est en train de se dire qu'à
laisser six pour kramnik tomber cette
fois ça y est il est dit obsédé topalov
ai dit je vais pouvoir pénétrer la casse
g7 et la casse g2 et la tour et check
point une pointe de chronique s'est pas
encore vraiment une poitiers celle c'est
à dire qu'il faut jouer ce à quoi j'ai 6
ans et 6 tours accueille des sans voix
là et là il ya là y'a plus on comprend
plus la colonie voilà donc la toute
dernière pour topalov qui peut répéter
les couvrir
mais la d5 alors oui à moi je sens que
ça commence à être un micro voilà ça
commence à être un micro la chronique ça
et perd son centre un peu il veut
essayer de simplifier la position est là
et on parle c'est de garder leur des
pions avec le ciné les comme stéphane
que prend des cinq à la passe de cinq
c'est quand même le coût principal dans
cette position section comptait 5
enfin le coût qui al'air principal ici
on attend après qu'il ait des cadres qui
est l'idée ce qui a contraint
franchement des quatre voies la prendre
pour reprendre clause 3 avec un point
que le tout à fait donc ici c'est pas
bon donc il adviendra les gîtes au pâlot
fils a joué aux cinq encore tout ça pour
museler ce cavalier seul une défense en
direct en fait le point sur les fonds
serviraient de ps3 mais ce club un peu
plus sa voiture et par là bas ça fait
toujours un cap maintenant attaque le
cavalier ça c'est un joli coup ça ouais
tu attaques lecavalier
sur quels points f2 on voit pourquoi
venir en g3 et prend ensuite le pion à
tout moment voilà il était encore je me
sentais encore tout à fait jouable
bailly signaliez pas il n'y a pas 36
solutions comme on dit c'était pas mal
et praticiens gauche lecavalier il ya le
roi qui vont tous les problèmes de mais
voilà donc il a joué f5 laisse ni
topaloff
et là c'est la guerre c'est la guerre
voilà ça y est les bacs à force de
vouloir gagner
topalov craque ils oublient tout
simplement la fatigue bien mon celi qui
se pencheront pas en jeu c'est un petit
peu ça on sait pas est férié mais hélas
ils doivent tout simplement car il prend
8,5 et ça y est c'est terminé le pion
histoire va tomber il est public et pour
le 5 mai je sais pas ce qu'il est on
sait pas exactement à pirater la
machination ça arrive exactement en
plein là ça arrive même à ce niveau ce
qu'il faut signaler ces femmes c'est
important après tour à 4 le seul coup et
kerry point f2 roigé 3 wii et maintenant
la pointe ce4 voilà on donne le cavalier
après roman est celle qui lie à
perpétuer maintenant on peut tenter 3e
un échec encore michel leroy revient
oui devant les chutes ont avancé puisque
si le roi revient pas c'est à dire si on
joue roi des deux greffes de kiev 2 le
claude van damme est ensuite d'amour
donc ici après qu'ils aient rejeté le 4
3 pour être deux tours b deux échecs la
seule tentative sirois jeudi à moi j'ai
trois mois j'ai trois enregistrements
qui est une autre possibilité est au
rouge bien c'est pareil on continue à
mitrailler d'échec sur ces deux gaz là
est tout à fait le roi qui se déplacera
sur une de ces trois cases et ça ça
serait ce serait une gaffe et roger
trois tours j'ai deux échecs tout rejet
de l'échec est là et roidot bouaré et de
la tour doit venir s'interposer
hélas quand on gêne tant chez ben voilà
on peut plus empêcher la dame à tour est
attaqué et si on prend la tour
évidemment ses pions prend tour avec
dame et la ceca n'est donc laissé après
tout à 4 il a vraiment craqué quel point
f2 faisait nul grâce à cette petite
astuce que nous venons voir et après le
coup et cinq et bien maintenant c'est
une question de technique pour venir car
microsoft ou les taupes allofs s'écroule
donc là il élira vitres et les radis
kramnik alors là oui bah cramique
ensuite un conclu on peut regarder
rapidement les derniers coups tomber
deux je ne sais pas ce que total aux
fans donc java qui va essayer d essayer
de squeeze et un peu l'adversaire mais
non il n'a pas peur cranie qui défend en
fait son pion à f2 il prend même plus ce
pion maintenant il va faire la
différence avec son pion passé mais il
envoie que le prochain coup de l'avenir
chronique c'est tour des cadres la tour
qui défendra le cavalier ont des trois
ans la tour ici et pour pousser le pion
aux concepteurs et sa défense qui avait
déployé plus de solution maintenant
toutes les pièces blanches sont
extrêmement fortes tombées cette crainte
a pas la forme pêche ses pions d'avancé
tour des quatre quand même alors on veut
pousser les pions certainement tombé six
des six as et le pion pouces attention
les emprises parce qu'il est en prise du
cavalier de la tour donc ya pas chouette
homologue faut le prendre puisque deux
ces menaces avec avec dame
donc il faut prendre et dans le cas d'un
diplôme qu'elle peut revoir voilà le roi
revient et on va prendre le pion et ça
fait de plus en plus donc on va vite
terminée par cavaliers aux quatre roues
avec 3,3 g 5 h quatre échecs jusqu'à
leur échec une petite pointe
supplémentaire sur voie pour acheter a
travaillé ces cinq six ans avec deux
options plus en finale deux tours ayant
tout de suite instantanément au f 6
tours de 5 me la chronique il est
vraiment sur son terrain toutes ces
pièces sont trop bien placé
amalyte obtient de plus en finale retour
cavaliers s'est perdu topalov à craquer
échec
c'est incroyable dans cette farine avec
c'était la nouvelle de cette première
partie topalov crac lac de toba l'ofs
donc il ya quelques coups de jouer voilà
on voit chronique qui replace toujours
pour tomber à chaque échec le plan tombe
calais dès là encore une fois et là qu'a
lieu de voilà qui empêche toute de
pénétration à la tour des 5 et ça va ici
c'est terminé le canadien ne peut plus
être défendu
y'a plus qu'à tours bien tomber un don
qu'il a abandonné dans cette loi un tour
bien et la tournée des quatre cadets 4
ensuite on va le prendre c'est un
crochet droit on défend et 2 tours 3 fc
termine c'est terminé ça fera trois
points de plus donc paris première
partie quand même spectaculaire
spectaculaire l'alameda topalov la mitis
john d je sais pas faire comme on dit
il donne le bâton pour se faire battre
en fait alors je ne dirais pas ça parce
que total of conan ce régulièrement ces
tournois par des défaites
oui c'est vrai aussi c'est il faut
qu'ils chauffent quoi c'était un simple
diesel soit face à louis xi sauf à saint
louis ce qu'il a commencé par six et
demi sur cette quelqu'un le résultat le
plus impressionnant qu'on ait vu dans
l'histoire des échecs pratiquement donc
topaloff est un peu un diesel dans
certains tournois par exemple au tournoi
hem tél
il avait commencé en perdant des partis
mais il a fini avec un trois et demi sur
4 je prends ou quelque chose comme ça on
va voir la suite évidemment sur la
prochaine émission on va quand même
revoir cette dernière image de cramique
donc tout expliquent tout est expliqué
maintenant qu'il est content il a dit
que l'art est la conférence précédant
qu'il est heureux d'avoir gagné cette
partie et que bon mais il méritait pas
certainement pas la gagner mais bon
comme on l'a vu toute façon il méritait
pas de la peur non plus et il a bien
joué il a drivé par ce délire koh lanta
palau aurait dû prendre un nul
il a voulu forcer son destin résultat il
a pris une bulle il est dominé pour
l'instant suite du match lors de cette
deuxième partie
à très bientôt sur les modalités